hello welcome to the first Henry Louis
Gates Jr lecture I'm very very happy to
see all of you here today my name is
Elizabeth Alexander and I'm the chair of
the African American Studies department
here at Yale before we go any further I
want us to pause for a moment and
remember our very very dear friend and
colleague Mary odo cemento Kyle who
passed away yesterday after a long
illness for many years as the director
of this space the Whitney Humanities
Center she filled it with intellectual
and cultural energy and excellence not
to mention her own extraordinary sense
of style and spirit and her true and
evident love for life that's what she
gave to this place year after year so we
miss her very much and this will always
be her space so let's just take a moment
to remember her
okay today's event which were very
excited about is happening because of
the generosity of Daniel and Joanna Rose
mr. Rose wanted to do something at Yale
for his dear friend skip gates and I'm
extremely honored that his gift will
rest in the department of
african-american studies his gift will
allow us to host a major lecture each
year of the scale of this one with
cutting edge thinkers in the far-flung
and fascinating terrain of the broadest
definition of african-american studies
each year guests will come and spend the
day with us first in the department as
we did today with professors Apia and
gates talking with our graduate students
and our faculty and then with the entire
Yale and New Haven communities invited
to hear new work these lectures will be
collected in book form and I envision
these volumes to be must reads for
people to see what's happening on the
cutting edge of our field with
lectureships of this stature we further
solidify and expand the work that we're
doing here in the classroom in
conversation with each other and with
the scholarship that we're putting out
into the world this is work that is
resonant with the roses concerns and
commitments over many many many years
mr. Rose writes and speaks extensively
on issues and challenges facing black
communities and among many many other
extraordinary legacies he has built the
Harlem education activities fund which
has supported hundreds and hundreds of
young people through successful high
school college and postgraduate careers
very quietly he buys thousands of
volumes of books and gives them away to
students in public schools especially in
New York City and now he is enabling us
to do this here at Yale skip gates did
so much to build african-american
studies at Yale when he was an assistant
professor along with our inaugural
lecturer and the friendship between
professors gates in Apia began in the
classroom and developed as they taught
together at Yale in another beautiful
era of african-american studies with
Charles Davis and John Blasingame as
chairs and architect
we here have continued to grow and build
and so obviously has skip obviously and
the special significance
mr. rose of this lecture is that your
generosity has enabled us to be able to
honor skip where he was an undergraduate
where his mind was shaped and caught
fire from his brilliant classmates and
from his teachers we had the privilege
of hearing about that at lunch today so
thank you mr. rose for enabling us to
honor our beloved skip dates and thank
you for the spotlight you helped to
shine on african-american studies at
Yale emanating around the world thank
you so much
and just a word on the many who have
worked so hard on this event it's had
many hands and many elves in the
workshop
especially Lisa Monroe and Philip green
in the Department of african-american
studies
Regina stirrer olace and Nina glitzen in
the president's office the great Dian
witty and Hilary Brown in the
development office this has been a major
undertaking for us but now we have a
template for doing it in the future and
our plans for this lecture are to hold
it in celebration every early fall and
as I said to bring the work together in
book form and so now I'm going to
introduce our speaker for today Anthony
Appiah after his lecture I'll returned
to the stage and say a few words about
Henry Louis Gates before he then closes
our afternoon and you'll then join us at
a reception right down the hallway in
his book in my father's house Anthony
Appiah wrote quote if my sisters and I
were children of two worlds no one
bothered to tell us this we lived in one
world in two extended families divided
by several thousand miles and an
allegedly insuperable cultural
difference that never so far as I can
recall puzzled or perplexed us much as I
grew older and went to English boarding
school I learned that not everybody had
family in Africa and in Europe not
everyone had a Lebanese uncle American
and French and Kenya and Thai cousins
and by now now that my sisters have
married a Norwegian and a Nigerian and a
Ghanaian now that I live in America I am
used to seeing the world as a network of
points of affinity it is this worldview
born at home grown at home that Anthony
Appiah has brought with such rigor and
elegance to his work over the years his
Cambridge dissertation explored the
foundations of probabilistic semantics
once revised these arguments were
published by Cambridge University Press
as assertions and conditionals and out
of that monograph grew a second book for
truth in semantics he has taught at Yale
as we've discussed Cornell Duke Harvard
universities has lectured at many other
institutions in the United States
Germany Ghana's
of Africa in France and is now a faculty
member at Princeton University where he
has appointments in the philosophy
department and the University Center for
human values as well as the Center for
African American Studies program in
African Studies and the program in
translation studies and the department
of comparative literature and politics
during his time at Yale he was one of
the architects of the African American
Studies curriculum especially at the
graduate level building of a vision that
we are carrying forth today he has
published widely in african american and
african literary and cultural studies in
1992 oxford published the book i quoted
from in my father's house which explores
among other things the role of African
and African American intellectuals in
shaping contemporary African cultural
life in 1996 he published color
conscious the political morality of race
with University of Pennsylvania
president Amy Gutmann in 1997 the
dictionary of global culture co-edited
with Henry Louis Gates Jr and edited the
Encarta africanus cd-rom encyclopedia
published by Microsoft which is an
encyclopedia of nothing no less than the
history of black people all over the
globe there are too many publications to
name I want to call note to boot meb a
Proverbs of the akan which he
co-authored with his mother the writer
Peggy Apia the annotated edition of
7,500 proverbs in twe that we find in
that book he's the author of three
novels as well and continuing in the
philosophical work the ethics of
identity and cosmopolitanism ethics in a
world of strangers he has been elected
to the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences the American Philosophical
Society and again this is selected the
American Academy of Arts and Letters
until 2009 he served as a trustee of
Ashesi University College in Accra and
now is on its academic advisory board he
has received honorary degrees from many
universities including Colgate
University Bard College
Fairleigh Dickinson's Swarthmore College
and after Colby College honored him with
a doctorate of laws in their one hundred
and eighty ninth commencement the next
one came when he was granted an honorary
doctorate of Humane Letters at a
convocation lecture at Berea College and
then the honorary degree of Doctor of
Laws at Harvard's 360 first commencement
he has been called and I love this our
postmodern Socrates I didn't make that
up but III will deploy it I think it's
fantastic and I would characterize his
work as posing questions and leading us
to conclusions which are not aimed to
comfort our most cherished forms of
selfhood but rather to disturb them he
scrutinizes Wraiths ethnicity gender
sexuality class religion nationhood with
an eye for the generative power of
understanding their ethical ambivalences
he does not aim to deny the legitimacy
of these large collective identities but
rather considers how obsessive loyalties
can threaten freedom and community his
thinking for words
Dubois his concept of double
consciousness at the turn of this
century professor Apia we welcome you
home to Yale african-american studies
for the first Henry Louis Gates Jr
please welcome the Lawrence s
Rockefeller University professor of
philosophy Anthony Appiah
thank you very much for that very kind
introduction and thank you Dad Thank You
skip and Thank You Yale which was the
institution that brought me to the
United States this was I first came to
United States as a visiting graduate
student here under the care of Charles
Davis in african-american studies and
Ruth Marcus in philosophy whom we've
also recently lost but so I owe a very
great deal to this institution
as I recall there were just two
undergraduates of African descent at
Clare College Cambridge in England in
1972 I was a medical student and the
other one was a philosopher a Nigerian
but we were joined the next year by a
recent Yale graduate the first African
American Mellon fellow at the college
who had who arrived as it happens with
the first woman to receive that honor
his name as I'm sure you will anticipate
was Henry Louis Gates Jr we became as he
will also anticipate the best of friends
he told me later but in the first weeks
that he was in college people kept
asking him if he'd met Anthony Appiah
and being a smart fellow he came pretty
quickly quickly to the conclusion but I
too must be as no one at Claire would
ever have said out loud a black person
so I have known the scholar we are
celebrating today for nearly 40 years
skip studies Cambridge with the great
Nigerian critic poet novelist and
dramatist wala Shu Inka who was a
visitor to the University in those days
it was through skip that I meant wale
and the three of us dined together from
time to time over hearty food and
steadily improving wine in those dinner
conversations and in hundreds of others
with skipped I was persuaded for the
first time that the questions that
interested him about race and culture
and identity were not just existential
questions but academic questions as well
so I owe that to him and it was indeed
he who persuaded me to come to Yale into
America for the first time in 1978 it
was largely because of him that I had a
great time here as a visiting graduate
student and it was he who convinced me
when I was finishing my PhD a couple of
years later that I ought to consider a
job here he probably was the person who
persuaded Yale that they ought to
consider me now I knew about
pan-africanism of course before I met
skip the one thing my father knew wb2
voice and so the great man at the 1945
pan-african conference in Manchester
which my father attended as a member of
wasa who the West African Students Union
which he went on to lead as its
president but pan-africanism was
something we lived in our family George
Padmore substituted for in crummy and
creamer is best man at my parents
wedding Richard Wright that's my parents
wedding Pat Moore is invisible on behind
my father's left right children Richard
Richard Wright and CLR James both
visited our home in Ghana when I was a
child James Baldwin and Maya Angelou
were in our library so a pan-african
identity was as I say something
existential rather than something
theoretical but I think it was skip who
turned this family project of mine into
a scholarly interest soon I found myself
teaching my first class at Yale a
college seminar and the spring of 1979
on pan-africanism spending time buried
deep in the Sterling library stacks
trying to keep ahead of the students I
can still recall the excitement of
finding in the open stacks a box of
pamphlets of independent state speeches
in Liberia from the mid 19th century
including one by Alexander crummell an
African American who graduated from
Cambridge rather earlier than skip and I
did in 1853 I hope I've told you enough
to explain how honored and delighted I
am to be giving the first Henry Louis
Gates Jr lecture here at Yale and I hope
you'll forgive me for selecting as the
subject of that first lecture not one of
your alumni but the first African
American to get the PhD at Harvard
conceding to you that the first African
American to get the PhD was a Yale man
who got it a good deal earlier in
physics my subject is identity and WB
Dubois his contributions to our
understanding of it I want to begin by
trying to disentangle one of Du Bois his
most distinctive paradox is the
combination of a respect for
individuality with a deep concern for
various groups to which he belonged and
the related conjunction of his global
and local identifications will handle
these difficulties best I'm going to
argue by recognizing devices immersion
in the German philosophical traditions
of the late 19th century what a
historian once called Dubois his love
affair with Imperial Germany persisted
even after the country had travelled the
route from the nationalism of the 19th
century to National Socialism Du Bois
was not blind
to German anti-semitism either in the
early 1890s in his graduate years in
Berlin or in a much more virulent forms
it took in the 1930s when he visited
Nazi Germany in 1936 he wrote that the
campaign I'm quoting the campaign of
race prejudice surpasses in vindictive
cruelty and public insult anything I've
ever seen and I have seen much and he
went on to say there's been no tragedy
in modern times equal in it's awful
effects to the fight on the Jew in
Germany it is an attack on civilization
comparable
only to such horrors of the Spanish
Inquisition and the African slave trade
you should recall that these words were
written before the campaign of mass
murder began but Germany was the first
country in which two boys himself
experienced life without the daily
cruelties and public insults of racism I
had a strong affection for Germany he
once said because in the days of my
storm and man's characteristic Dubois II
and formulations this was the land where
I first met white folk who treated me as
a human being this is a mild
exaggeration perhaps but still that's
what he felt clearly a sense of personal
liberation was one of his major debts to
his German experience the second death
was intellectual tobias developed as a
graduate student in germany a lasting
framework for thinking about the
relation between race and nation culture
and politics Russel Berman has written
insightfully about the German strain and
DuBose's
thinking about race nation and culture
something that was there in embryo
before his arrival in Germany his
commencement address at Fisk in 1888
took Bismarck as a model of a
nation-building hero in employing the
German Chancellor to stand for an idea
device displays as vermin seized and
incipient a galleon ISM this tendency
would have been encouraged at Harvard
where a prominent near the galleons were
not in short supply but his intellectual
debt to Germany was deepened by his
schooling in Berlin where he studied
with Adele Pardoner Gustav Mahler and
William built-i and heard lectures by
Heinrich von Tresckow it was training in
swallows graduate seminar that prepared
him for the work of the Philadelphia
negro and Robert Goulet Gooding Williams
has shown how Dubois his basic
philosophical picture oh as much to a
broadly Hegelian nationalism and more
particularly to swallows social
philosophy one way to enter that milia
is to go back to Johann Gottfried herder
the great German philosopher of
Romanticism who was preoccupied like Du
Bois with the question of original
had our thought of originality as
Charles Taylor's pointed out among
others at two levels both at the level
of the individual distinct from the
other individuals from all other
individuals and at the level of the
people distinct from other people's and
Dubois who grew on that had Aryan
tradition there is an awful lot of hair
that had drawn had no difficulty in
stressing the importance of the
development of race groups as well as
personal individuality to speak in the
language that we inherit from
romanticism you're being a German can
shape the authentic self whose
expression is the project of your life
individuality is inflected by
collectivities on this romantic picture
for however every nation has a governing
spirit it's Fox Geist a word one might
translate as folk soul or folk spirit
which is expressed in every aspect of
its social and cultural being so the
character of each people can be found
not only in the writing of its literary
geniuses in Goethe and elder lien but
also in its folklore the folk songs and
the folktales collected for example
under head as inspiration by Jakob and
Wilhelm Grimm between Oh as Grimm's
fairy tales at the point for the Grimm
brothers was they were collecting as it
were data about the Fox Geist about the
German thoughts code they were mistaken
and their belief that that was doing
because many of these folktales turned
out to have originated for example in
France and in Persia but that's another
document so sorry how they would have
understood why Dubois prefaced each
chapter of the souls of black folk with
both a literary epigraph and a phrase of
a Negro spiritual this is a copy of a
page of the manuscript of the souls of
black folk Negro spirituals were the
folk song of his people Du Bois his
indication of his intellectual legacy
the theory of the false case is hard to
avoid it is almost there in the title of
his most famous work he is showing his
readers the geister this is the plural
of Geist of a black folk for her
as for the boys each folks guys
possesses something of distinctive value
nevertheless had also insisted that this
mention can select a gauche like a stun
gun says there are biting underlings and
Alton Fernanda humankind is a single
thing a whole we work and suffer sow and
reap for each other indeed part of the
providential point of human history is
that each people each folk should
express its distinctive character
through its particular history because
is only through because it is only
through each nation's following its
distinctive path but history as a whole
can achieve its meaning there is a word
for the character of the nationalism
that device expressed it is cosmopolitan
in the conservation of races an essay
I'll return to in a moment he writes
that the Negro race and all the others
are quote striving each in its own way
to develop for civilization its
particular message premature even here
he speaks not just of racial but of
human Brotherhood devices cosmopolitan
as well in his openness to the
achievements of other civilizations his
celebration of European culture is
always evident in the souls of black
folk we can see this in the coming of
John when quote the black John is moved
beyond measure by vergas music sorry
when the black John has moved beyond
measure by Vargas music quote he sat in
dreamland and started when after a hush
rose high and clear the music of learn
grins Swan the infinite beauty of the
whale lingered and slept and swept
through every muscle of his frame and
put it all attune the heard Aryan strain
in devices count for cosmopolitanism is
evident to in his citations not just a
German high culture but a folk culture
as well as when he quotes a German folk
song in the final pages of the souls
gets gay and spleen alert think of an it
you might translate this as now as go
into the well but ain't gonna drink
and maybe Alistair let's see I get this
to work I'm not sure I can actually play
that little clip that's sitting down
there but it's very charming do Boyce's
cosmopolitanism is not just the static
he accepts the cosmopolitan moral idea
that he has obligations to those outside
his racial horizon and finally he is
cosmopolitan in his methods insisting on
a globally comparative perspective even
when he's talking about the United
States Dubois sees the problem of the
Jim Crow for example as part of a larger
tragedy the color line imposes Jim Crow
in Georgia but it also imposes a
destructive colonialism and what he
regularly called in one of his many
poetical formulations Asia and Africa
and the islands of the sea so the Boise
was an aesthetic a moral and a
methodological cosmopolitan how much
more of a commitment to a sense of
global citizenship can we ask for he not
only went went to the well of
cosmopolitanism he drank deeply from it
like the person who went to the brunella
for all that contemporary readers will
be inclined to think across a palton
nationalism as an oxymoron surely
cosmopolitanism the idea that all human
beings are in some sense fellow citizens
of the world is the very opposite of
nationalism the conviction that the
boundaries of nationality should be the
boundaries of citizenship this is not an
argument that would have been snared
someone with two voices intellectual
background Friedrich Monaco who was only
a little older than device and who like
him had studied with troika wrote just
five years after the souls was published
cosmopolitanism and nationalism stood
side by side in a close living
relationship for a long time the title
of the book in which he wrote these
words was veldt Berger tomb with
nacional start cosmopolitanism in the
nation-state in the national state the
19th century theorists of European
nationalism recognized that the demand
for national rights only made sense as a
moral demand if it was claimed equally
for all nation
the structure of the argument is one
that Kant made familiar my dignity
cannot matter because it is mine it has
to matter because it is dignity and if
dignity is what matters
your dignity matters too so mutatis
mutandis for nationality my national
nation cannot matter because it mine
must matter because it's a nation and if
nation nationality is what matters then
your nationality matters due but the
voice the destiny of the Negro was to be
understood as a strand in a larger human
destiny his nationalism never descended
into chauvinism when he is critical of
white people it's typically for a
failure to honor the very universality
of the values they espouse in making
these arguments in the American context
Du Bois is not of course by any means
unique the search for a proper balance
between the local and the universal can
be found as well in the contemporaneous
writings of others of de voices another
of devices teachers Josiah Royce who was
like Du Bois a careful student of German
Romanticism in June 1902 five years
after Du Bois had published the earlier
version of the first essay of the souls
in the Atlantic Monthly Royce defended
what he called famously provincialism in
an essay to the Phi Beta Kappa society
at the University of Iowa was just the
temptation to comment on talking about
provincialism in Iowa by provincialism
he said he meant first the tendency of a
province to possess its own customs and
ideals secondly the totality of these
customs and ideals themselves and
thirdly the love and pride which leads
the inhabitants of a province to cherish
as their own these traditions beliefs
and aspirations brushes the fence of
this provincialism as quote a saving
power to which the world in the near
future will need more and more to appeal
might startle a contemporary reader used
to the idea that provincial is a
criticism not a compliment but price
also recognize the dangers of what he
called false forms of provincialism like
the German patriotism he was borrowing
from his nationalism and his
cosmopolitanism like the voices stood
side-by-side
in a closed living relationship device
to always recognized the risk that black
folk would facing hostility from their
white brethren withdraw from the
vivifying contact with other nations and
peoples he makes the point in dusk of
dawn when he talks of the way American
racism in prisons black people within
the race practically this group
imprisonment within a group has various
effects upon the prisoner he tends to
neglect the wider aspects of national
life and human existence on the one hand
he's unselfish so far as his inner group
is concerned he thinks of himself not as
an individual but as a group man a race
man his loyalty to his group idea this
idea group idea tends to be almost an
ending and bulks at almost no sacrifice
on the other hand his attitude towards
the environment eels into a matter of
unreasoning resentment and even hatred
deep disbelief in them and refusal to
conceive honesty and rational thought on
their part its attitude adds to the
difficulties of conversation intercourse
understanding between groups notice that
everything Dubois says here about black
people enclosed within an American
context can be applied equally to white
Americans who have closed themselves off
from the world the formulation seems
deliberately abstract it unfurls a
general critique of anti cosmopolitan
forms of nationalism and indeed in the
1920s ada sells white folk Du Bois
expressed pity for white Americans quote
imprisoned and enthralled hampered and
made miserable by racism in very much
the same terms and what had such
prisoners closed themselves off from
well Du Bois his most memorable
formulation of his ideal can be found
decades earlier in the souls of black
folk there he spoke with a cosmopolitan
instinct for conversation across peoples
in these justly famous words across the
color line I move in arm arm-in-arm with
Bowser and Umar where smiling men and
welcoming women to hide in gilded halls
from out the caves of evening that swing
between the straw
and the tracery of the stars I summon
Aristotle and Aurelius and what soul I
will and they come all graciously with
no scorn or nor condescension so weighed
with truth I'd well above the veil
Dubois was in the course of a long life
a citizen as we all are of more than one
policy of Massachusetts in Georgia and
New York of the United States of Ghana
and of course less literally of the
Academy but he was also always a citizen
of the world
this was no stretch for someone who
grassed with the German intellectuals
whose insights were largely lost over
the course of the last century the
cosmopolitanism and nationalism should
be allies rather than adversaries as I
said just now invoking a style of
argument that goes back at least account
my nationality cannot matter because it
is mine it has to matter because it is
nationality and devices cosmopolitanism
was indeed infused with the second of
the themes that I'm going to talk about
today the issue of a black racial
identity as we see again and again Du
Bois like most great intellectuals was
not just a creative producer but also a
voracious consumer of ideas and in
developing and refining his
understanding of black identity what it
means to be a Negro as he would have put
it he drew on other scholarly
developments changes in the social and
biological sciences that challenged the
racial thinking of the 19th century in
which he was reared we can see something
of the character was thought about black
identity in the conservation of races
published in 1897 the question we must
seriously consider argues is this what
is the real meaning of race and he
answers first that the real the final
word of science so far is that we have
at least two perhaps three great
families of human beings the whites and
Negroes possibly the yellow race what
matters about these races that science
has discerned however is not quote The
Grocer physical differences of color
hair and bone but the quote differences
subtle delicate and elusive though they
may be which have silently but
definitely separated men into
oops what these subtle forces while
these subtle forces have generally
followed the natural cleavage of common
blood descent and physical peculiarities
they have at other times swept across
and ignored these at all times however
they have divided human beings into
races which while they perhaps transcend
scientific definition nevertheless are
clearly defined to the eye of the
historian and sociologist so what the
Boise is insisting on here is an account
of racial or national membership that is
focused on the ideas expressed in the
collective life of the people and an
insisting on this he is thinking about
national history in the way that it
would have been taught both at Harvard
and the University of Berlin it was
after all the standard understanding of
Hegel's philosophy of history that human
experience was the working out of an
idea
in fact of something called the idea in
history and the less metaphysical
version of the story that divorced
Burroughs not so much from philosophers
but from historians nations are the
natural historical expressions not of
the grand Universal idea but of less
grand particular ideas the English
nation Du Bois stands for constitutional
Liberty and commercial freedom the
German for science and philosophy the
romance nations for yes you guessed it
literature and art if these are the
capital I ideas of these people Du Bois
is searching for the Negro capital I
idea the full complete message of the
Negro race has not yet been given to the
world the question is then how shall
this message be delivered how shall
these various ideals be realized
the answer is plain by the development
of these race groups not as individuals
but as racists early Negroes inspired by
one vast ideal can work out its fullness
in its fullness the great message we
renewed reserve for Humanity
now we're inclined nowadays to suppose
that what bound Negroes to each other
from divorce must have been a biological
theory of race what else would a
Victorian thinker believe he had why
else would a Victorian thinkable
evie had anything in common with people
raised in an entirely different culture
and climate on a continent thousands of
miles away but we can tell from da
boys's
easy movement between talk of race and
talk of nation but his conception was
not what we would call biological but
for those who keeping track that's a
retraction of something I said in the
most famous paper ever written about
having to be divisive what mattered he
thought what mattered he thought
we're not physical differences but quote
the deeper differences which are
spiritual psychical differences that's
why we can properly speak of his
attitude of his racial identity as a
form of nationalism he believed about
the Negro race what an American patriot
of his day wouldn't relieved about
America except that it needed a single
country a nation-state to gather its
people in so he believed in the grou
national character a Negro national
destiny and he thought it was the duty
of black people especially of the most
talented black people to work together
in service of the Negro people but by
the first decades of the 20th century
academic thinking about race was
beginning to shift Mendel's ideas were
rediscovered around 1900 by 1915 Thomas
H Morgan who was to receive the first
Nobel Prize for medicine in 1933 had
published with his co-authors a book
called the mechanism of Mendelian
heredity based in large measure on work
on the inheritance of mutations in the
fruit fly he made famous Drosophila
melanogaster it's because of Morgan that
I spent time in my high school dad
playing around with these beastly flies
the astonishing advances in genetics a
term that it was itself coined by
William Bateson the Cambridge in about
1905 in the first two decades of the
century forced a general rethinking of
the biology of heritable characteristics
within a generation
there was a synthesis of Mendelian
genetics in Darwinian evolutionary
theory in the work of the population
geneticists led by JB Hall Dean RA
Fisher and seal right and this union of
Mendelian and Darwinian ideas one whose
broad features remain part of the
contemporary scientific picture this
believed by 40% of the American
population
received its canonical expression in
civilian Huxley's elegant 1942 book
evolution the modern synthesis at the
same time changes were occurring in the
ways in which people thought about the
relationship between biology and culture
in the wake of the new population
genetics one no leaguer longer needed to
think of the physical appearance and the
character of the Negro as the common
products of a shared essence meanwhile
there were new advances in anthropology
developed among others by Franz boas who
left the Royal ethnographic Museum in
Berlin to move to New York five years
before device arrived at the 3d film
university well as his empirical
fieldwork undermined many of the claims
about race and about cultural
development that dominated the writings
of earlier geographers and natural
historians Du Bois invited though ass
who was then a professor of anthropology
at Columbia to give a commencement
address at Atlanta University when he
was a professor there in 1906 much later
in the book black folk then and now
published in 1939 Du Bois recorded the
impact of Boris's words on his
developing ideas Franz Boas came to
Atlanta University where I was teaching
history in 1906 and said to a graduating
class you need not be ashamed of your
African past and then he recounted the
history of the black kingdoms south of
the Sahara for a thousand years I was
too astonished to speak all of this I'd
never heard and I came then and
afterwards to realize how the silent
silence and neglect of science can let
truth
utterly disappear or even be
unconsciously distorted so the voice was
clearly aware of the developments in
biology and anthropology as they
occurred and he shared his changing
understanding with a wider world of back
intellectuals in the crisis which he
edited for so many years some drew the
conclusion and many still do that at
this point there is no longer any reason
to take racial grouping seriously if the
properties that members of array share
or share are only the superficial
phenotypic ones that we use in social
life to assign people to these
categories they have only superficial
things in common but Du Bois never drew
that conclusion although he understood
that the Western race concept
not be elucidated in purely biological
terms he believed that there was
something important that members of a
race did share and that something was
important enough to make being a Negro
central to his own self understanding
what could that something be the answer
was he said as we saw closely defined
clearly defined to the eye of the
historian and sociologist the Boyce's
development of what we would now call a
social constructionist account of race
started early already in the essay of
1897 which I've already quoted the
conservation of races
he'd argued that the human science is
not the Natural Sciences would uncover
the real meaning of race informed by the
new biology of the first decades in 20th
century he came to see that you could
define races by genetically transmitted
physical characteristics without
thinking that the forms of racial
difference really mattered the social
life were consequences of an underlying
biology contemporary readers may find
these points obvious this is a measure
of how pervasive the new understanding
has become with its picture of
inheritance as particulate and it's
distinction between biological and
cultural transmission so it's worth
underlining that our common sense here
is new and the Dubois was among the
first people in the world fully to grasp
its significance we have new language
for some of these insights we speak of
race as I say as a species of social
construction with species of social
identity and we have insights now that
were not fully available to Dubois
so I'm going to lay out the general
outlines of our contemporary
understanding before returning to the
ways that Du Bois anticipated it there
are four crucial them critical
dimensions of the contemporary
philosophical understanding of identity
first social identities depend for their
existence none of this is
uncontroversial I'm just giving you the
correct account first social identities
depend for their existence and their
being labels for them this is because
people respond to others and think of
themselves by way of these labels we
think of people as Caucasians or
Canadians or Catholics and then respond
to them as such we think of ourselves
and Americans and do or abstain from
doing things because that is what we
think we are so the fine first bite
physical nominalism about social
identities is preferable to ontological
realism what holds groups together is
often not a shared essence but the
practices that develop around a shared
name so we can say in a slogan that
social identities require labels social
identity labels are often contested at
the boundaries is the daughter of an
african-american and an Eskimo raised in
Alaska really black is the son of an
African and a native Hawaiian really
Hawaiian we must accept that can be
endless argument about such things
the contestability of the boundaries is
I think the main reason my nominalism
seems to be the only view about
identities that will do to say that
boundaries are contestable isn't to say
that there are no clear cases of course
if once the evidence is in you judge
them for our course and Obama isn't a
man or al sharpton isn't an
african-american we will have lost our
semantic bearings altogether there can
be clear answers to questions about the
description of concepts with fuzzy edges
listen knowledge contestability built
into our use of the terms is
suggestively like the essential
contestability of many normative
concepts which WB galle pointed to back
in the 1950s and indeed the second
dimension of identity that i want to
point to is precisely that there are
norms associated with social identities
norms of identification i'll call them
which specify ways that people of a
certain identity ought to behave and
norms of treatment ways that people of a
certain identity ought or ought not to
be responded to and acted upon and my
shorthand for this second claim is that
identity is normative the third
dimension of identity flows from this
second because there are norms of
identical difficut identification people
who identify through the labels as X act
sometimes as X's by which I mean that
one reason they act as they do is that
they are motivated by the thought I have
a reason to do this thing because I am
an X this last point makes explicit the
fact that we now see identities as
centrally subjective in the sense that
their importance derives from the role
they play in the thoughts and acts of
those who bear them
so identities we now think are nominal
normative and subjective all of the
things bees being features of course
that may explain why we routinely speak
of them as socially constructed that the
identities I am talking about are
subjective in this way is a key part of
the view we pick out the subjective
identities because they have a crucial
role in the making of our lives
notice that this theory brings together
points that Dubois was among the first
to make clearly about one social
identity namely negro we can begin with
devices recognition that race as a
species of social identity is made in
and through social processes we could
distinguish as he did between the output
and visible signs what he called the
badge of hair in color on the one hand
on the basis of which we assign people
to these groups and the social meaning
of their membership in identifying the
key role of the racial label Dubois his
approach expresses a form of nominalism
we can also see with him that the
ethical significance of our identities
derives from the way in which they give
us projects from the fact as he put it
in his negro Creed more than a century
ago but people have a shared identity
strive quotes together for the
accomplishment of certain more or less
vividly conceived ideals of life but we
can grasp too that the meaning of an
identity is determined not just by the
bearers of the badge but by the
responses of others that as he once put
it the black man is a person who must
ride Jim Crow in Georgia and we
understand as Dubois did that we can
have many identities and put one of them
to take up and celebrate is a
cosmopolitan identity as human beings
citizens of the world we share more
specifically when it comes to the negro
identity Du Bois saw that identity could
be grounded not in blood but in a place
and in an identification with its
history once he understood the Negro
socially historically the significance
of African descent didn't need to lie in
the genes that African Americans brought
from Africa it could lie in cultural
traditions of the continuing
significance of a black identity in the
present because black people share a
black identity
and that identity is narratively ruses
in Africa what happens in and to Africa
affects back people everywhere through
their own identifications as well as
through the views of others and here Du
Bois anticipates another modern insight
about social identity which is how
central narrative is to it it's as the
bearer of a Negro identity not as the
bearer of Egyptian genes that he can
find inspiration in the achievements of
pharaonic Egypt and one aspect of Du
Bois his commitment as a Negro was his
engaging with the history of Africa not
just with what happened in Africa in the
past but with durations of an African
past he wrote many African histories
just as American patriots live their
identity through stories of America
stories rooted somewhat loosely
sometimes in the soil of historical fact
so a black identity engages you with
tales of an African past told right of
course such stories bind people together
so they can accomplish shared goals this
point it is an astronaut's famous
insight about the connection between
historical narratives and nationalism is
one on which two boys relied on the many
occasions that he sought to rally black
people to the cause of black liberation
but Du Bois his connection to Africa and
to a Negro identity was made not just in
his formidable brain but in his pulsing
heart in his 1942 autobiography of a
race concept he writes with all the
characteristic feeling all his
characteristic feeling of his arrival on
the African continent for the first time
just before Christmas 1923 as the
American representative to the
inauguration of a new Liberian president
when shall I forget the night I first
set foot on African soil
I am the sixth generation in dissent
from forefathers who left this land the
moon was at the fall in the waters of
the Atlantic lay like a lake all the
long afternoon as the Sun roped herself
in her western scarlet with veils of
misty cloud I had seen Africa far
perhaps Du Bois his largest achievement
is to have found a way to express his
theoretical insights in language that
makes his ideas both memorable
uplifting addressing mind and heart
together and I want to remind you in
closing of one of these passages
well that is relatively well known is
its once more from dusk of dawn ladd
autobiography in fact just a page
earlier than his rapturous effusions
about those first African steps for in
this passage written in his 70s Du Bois
encapsulates most of his theory of a
black identity in his own inimitable
style here explicitly in the context of
his own life story he set out to answer
Countee Cullen's famous question what is
Africa to me once I should have answered
the question simply I should have said
fatherland or perhaps better motherland
because I was born in the century when
the walls of race were clear and
straight when the world consisted of
mutually exclusive races and even though
the edges might be blurred there was no
question of exact definition and
understanding of the meaning of the word
but one thing is sure that is the fact
that since the 15th century these
ancestors of mine and their descendants
have had a common history have suffered
a common disaster and have one long
memory the actual ties of heritage
between the individuals of this group
vary with the ancestors that they have
in common with many others but the
physical bond is leased and the badge of
color relatively unimportant saved as a
badge the real essence of this kinship
is its social heritage of slavery the
discrimination and insult and this
heritage binds together not simply the
children of Africa but extends through
yellow Asia and into the South Seas it
is this unity that draws me to Africa
however much there is to contend with in
this passage it is both densely argued
and deeply moving
duska Dorne he he knew deeply moving
he knew that he lived in the dusk of
understanding in his more optimistic
moments he believed that the dawn would
follow and he may even have sense that
his own work might speed its arrival
it's an old African trick making the Sun
move faster if Du Bois is work still
manages to cast not a shadow but a glow
it's fueled by rooted cosmopolitanism
that enriches the drone of universe
sella tea with the lively humanism of
conversation that complicates the
tempting reduction of rapes reductionism
a race and that draws from a history of
suffering a buoyant sense of purpose and
of hope as skip gates career shows us
that buoyancy can be contagious I'm
grateful to the man we celebrate today
for turning my attention towards such
work and to the larger project as
advances in this as in many things I'm
following not just skips example but his
inspiration thank you very much
Thank You professor Apia never has
illuminating Du Bois been so rapturously
illuminated thank you very very much
we're going to conclude our program with
some words from Henry Louis Gates Jr
professor Gates is the rare a professor
known by face and name because the work
he has done has genuine reach in the
wonderful way that Professor Apia just
explained for us the way in which the
study of the particular takes us all
over the planet he made his name with
the brilliant signifying monkey but she
spoke with us about earlier today again
thinking about what an organic what a
ground-up african-american theory of
literature would look like and who can
forget the impact of that book and how
it changed black studies and how it
changed literary studies he helped to
build african-american studies here as I
have said and he truly ground up built
african-american studies at Harvard into
the mighty brother to us that it is
today and I want to say how happy I am
that our friends and dear colleagues
from Harvard have come for this
wonderful day professors William Julius
Wilson
marcelina Morgan Larry Bobo and my own
dear dissertation advisor Evelyn Brooks
Higginbotham so we're very very glad
that you've come for this wonderful
full day with us any proper introduction
of professor gates must be condensed and
I want to hear what he has to say too
but to say a few things he is the
Alphonse Fletcher University professor
at Harvard University as well as
director of the Dubois Institute for
African and African American research
his books and his documentaries go on
and on and on
most recently you've no doubt seen
blacks in Latin America which came out
from New York University Press and was a
PBS series faces of America one of his
most recent PBS documentaries tradition
and the black Atlantic criticism and
black and the black Atlantic criticism
in the African Diaspora these are just a
few recent books co-editor of
call-and-response key debates in African
American Studies that many of us teach
with it is the most wonderful book to
teach almost any African American
Studies class with he is editor-in-chief
of the route a daily online magazine
focusing on issues of interest to the
black community written from an
african-american perspective he has the
books go on and on and on and on and
really um I want I want to hear him talk
rather than list all of them but I want
to just note a few loose canons notes on
the culture war colored people a memoir
the future of the race co-authored with
Cornel West thirteen ways of looking at
a black man which is one of my personal
favorites in search of our roots how
nineteen extraordinary African Americans
reclaimed their past on and on he earned
his master's in PhD in English
literature from Clare College at the
University of Cambridge and more
importantly received his BA in English
literature summa [ __ ] laude from Yale
University in 1973 and has taught at
Yale Cornell and Duke University's he
has received I'm sure that this is an
old number and it's probably like a
month old 51 honorary degrees as well as
a MacArthur Foundation Genius grant and
more Awards than we could mentioned we
miss professor gates still at Yale but
we feel ourselves again in conversation
with our
friends at Harvard and we also know that
in his generosity we are in an
intellectual community that strives to
understand because of his example more
deeply the history culture social
movements and philosophical thought of
black people all over the globe before I
invite him to the stage I also have to
say that once your teacher always your
teacher so I'm especially happy to be
introducing someone I met 30 years ago
on this campus in the seminar black
women and their fictions my world was
changed ever more skip gates was the
teacher who brought me into the work I
do who called me in the teacher who
showed me how it could be done the
teacher whose own committed and
prodigious work is ever animated by a
true deep and abiding love for the
creative beauty brilliance foibles and
all else of black people when you make a
friendship that begins that way that
begins with a shared love of precious
books and in the case of
african-american literature of words
once neglected or lost to time those
connections are indelible rare and
beautiful so with all my heart and love
I want to welcome and I'll ask you to
join me the man whose work we honor
today with this lecture the man who we
love and who we welcome back to Yale
skip gates you so much Elizabeth for for
this date and I want to thank President
Levin and the Faculty of the Department
of african-american studies for making
this day possible it's difficult to for
me to think of a greater honor in the
life of a Yale alumnus and to have one's
alma mater create a lecture in one's
name and it's been launched with such
eloquence and grace by Kwame Anthony
Appiah I'm deeply appreciative and
honored Anthony that you accepted the
Faculty's invitation to do so Anthony
and I met 39 years ago this month at
Clair college at the University of
Cambridge and his friendship has been
sustaining
and is formidable intellect inspiring
since that time I can't think of a more
perfect person to launch this series
please give it up for Anthony
I'm also so deeply grateful to my
colleagues at Harvard for coming down
today and my two daughters who were here
my daughter Elizabeth my daughter Maggie
my daughter Maggie was married on
Saturday how about that so couldn't give
it up first a word about the man whose
idea this lecture series was on the
occasion of my 60th birthday I get a
phone call out of the blue from Dan Rose
saying that he and Joanna had a surprise
they had decided to endow a lectureship
in african-american studies and wanted
to do so in my name and to do so at Yale
which is Dan's alma mater as well and I
was stunned by their generosity of
spirit and after protesting that I was
not worthy of such an honor myself and
even suggesting other names that I felt
more appropriate for the name of this
lecture including Dan and Joanna's Dan
responded that he and Joanna had made
their decision there was nothing I can
do about now there's a tradition in
rabbinic Judaism that holds that there
are 36 humble righteous ones who keep
the world intact without the tzadikim as
they are called the world itself would
fray and disappear their identities are
hidden the Talmud is saying but I think
that we all know the identity of one
because Dan Rhodes is just such a Tzadik
this is someone with an amazing mind and
an equally amazing heart his love of
argument his keenness of intellect his
compassion his sense of justice these
are the compass points of his life and
they inspire everyone who knows him I
know that they humble and inspire me and
of course there's only one person whose
force of mind and character can humble
and inspire Dan Rose and that's his wife
Joanna rose
knowing these two has been one of the
great privileges of my life when I think
about all that Dan and Johanna have
accomplished with their philanthropy for
people of color and for the poor I
inevitably think the great W EB Dubois
who famously wrote in the souls that
quote we must not seek to make men
carpenters but to make carpenters men
and no single quote more fully embodies
the spirit in which the roses give than
this one as I said in the audience two
Saturdays ago to witness the induction
of Dan and Johanna into the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences I couldn't
help but think of how diligently Dan has
worked for so many years to ensure that
young men and women of color children
born into circumstances less than ideal
less than fair would one day find their
nametag at the high table of world
culture Frederick Douglass once said
that the slave yearned above all else
for quote a future with hope in it
unquote dan rose through a project he
created called the Harlem educational
activity fund has given over a thousand
poor brown and black children the least
fortunate among us that future with hope
in it including some who have even been
educated here at Yale ladies and
gentlemen please give it up for my
friend
dan and Johanna took this crazy idea of
theirs to Rick Levin who in turn took it
to dear Elizabeth what could one say
about Rick other than the fact that when
the history of this era and the long
life of Yale is written
no one will be recalled as a greater
president with a deeper commitment both
the cultural diversity and to the field
of african-american studies then he this
is someone who who always believed that
fields like African and african-american
studies should be at the heart of a
great liberal arts education and not
peripheral to it as an academic and an
institution builder Rick where's the
mantle of leadership with so much grace
and seeming effortlessness and Rickon
the university had been blessed to have
Elizabeth Alexander at the helm of the
department Elizabeth and I have been on
a long journey together and she just
said we met here in of course I taught
called black women and they're fictions
exactly 30 years ago this past September
so this is a sort of special anniversary
for us and she has since become a dear
dear friend I've read and taught her
fierce and beautiful poetry in criticism
I have cheered from the sidelines as she
is one prize after prize and recognition
of her contributions to contemporary
poetry and with the rest of the nation
and the world I watched with pride as
she delivered her poem praise song for
the day at Barack Obama's inauguration
in 2009 not only American poetry but
African American Studies are both much
richer for her being in them
thank you dear Fred for all that you
have done for our field for this great
University and for being
with your indulgence I'd like to spend
just a few minutes paying homage to my
mentors in african-american studies to
the people who brought me to the
proverbial table now my route to this
day really began on Wall Street not the
Wall Street in Manhattan but the much
more famous Wall Street in New Haven
first of the Yale Law School and then at
one of the community's best-known eating
establishments now who could have
imagined that the rebirth of Black
Studies would happen in a pizza shop in
New Haven Connecticut who would have
thought that a pizza shop should become
a stop on New Haven's Black History
Trail and not one of New Haven's great
pizza shops either like Pepe's or
secondly but Naples pizza nasalle Naples
has been remembered for generations of
jelly's for the astonishing capacity of
its slices to soak up in ordinate
amounts of alcohol consumed by
undergraduates late of a Saturday night
but it was also the site from the mid
70s until the mid 80s for one of the
greatest seminars in the history of
afro-american studies as we called
attend seminar a veritable salon really
held each morning over breakfast and
often resuming over lunch six days a
week at the same square table in the
restaurants middle dining room and
presided over by a young recently
tenured historian of slavery and the
south a professor named John Wesley
blessing game senior now no one knows
what special charms that Naples held for
John blessing it all we know is that in
Naples John had found his perch his
office away from his office and very
held court virtually all day long if you
wanted to have a meeting with John if
you wanted to talk about a paper you
were writing for one of his classes if
you wanted advice about a research
project if you wanted to discuss a pay
raise or your prospects for tenure it
was in Naples at John's table that these
discussions would be held surrounded by
those classic American diner white and
green
porcelain coffee cups ashtrays filled
with the remnants of pack after pack of
Winston's that John smoked one after the
other from dawn to dusk all the day long
blast as we called him affectionately it
come to campus during my Jean
junior year with great anticipation
since he was the first black scholar to
teach African American history at Yale I
had come to Yale in September 1969 one
of ninety-six black men and women who
were the first fruits of Yale's
adventure in affirmative action as an
undergraduate I was most interested in
American political history under the
mentorship of the great John Morton Blum
who directed my scholar of the house
project with tender loving care
it was mr. Blum and first told me that I
could become a scholar and or a
journalist and I owe more to him than I
could ever adequately express here but
just like everybody black at Yale in
1969 I enrolled in the history
departments introduction to Africa
afro-american history course taught by
William s McFeely who counted among his
teaching assistants a Yale graduate
student named Thomas Holt is Bill
Macpherson able to come off it was a
legendary course unfolding week to week
and the increasingly volatile atmosphere
of escalating protests against the
Vietnam War and the simultaneous
escalation of the persecution of the
Black Panther Party as well as the trial
of Black Panther leader Bobby Seale
taking place right here in New Haven in
a word the atmosphere in New Haven and
on campus was extraordinarily volatile
each class and adventure as we waited
for the revolution to come nobody missed
the class first because of the quality
of Professor McFeely's lectures and
second because the Panthers were just as
likely to show up on any given day
demand equal time to espouse their
10-point program and then attempt to
intimidate us into giving donations
supposedly for their free breakfast
program
professor McFeely's lectures were
vignettes of the black past which had an
uncanny way of serving as allegories for
what the black community was
experiencing today
I well remember his end of the second
Ricans and of the second reconstruction
lecture delivered just after Richard
Nixon on January 19th 1970 nominated the
conservative judge G Harold Carswell to
replace Abe Fortas of the court the room
was packed you could have heard a pin
drop threatening clouds were on the
horizon
professor McFeely warmed and unless we
were vigilant the very policies that had
brought all of us black kids to Yale
were going to be reversed by
conservative Supreme Court it was
history teaching designed as extended
metaphor for those who would soon be
history making themselves bill McFeely
who would go on to win a Pulitzer Prize
in history for his Magisterial biography
of us Grant was our guide into the
wonders of african-american history bill
McFeely also taught me something else
ladies and gentlemen and that is that
you don't have to look like an academic
subject to be an expert in that subject
and despite the fact that the more
militant among us had a most annoying
habit of standing up during question
period following his lectures to ask him
what he a white man was doing teaching a
black history course he never once lost
his patience or his composure never once
admonished the students for their
rudeness and he did all that he could do
to ensure that John Blasingame was hired
to replace him as head of that class
he's not here I think he was too feeble
to come down Elizabeth graciously
offered to send a car for him but in his
absence
please give it up for my mentor way
blast for his part thought that lecture
courses were most certainly not the most
effective way to teach and he did all
that he could do to discourage students
from attending his lectures within the
two weeks or so of shopping period his
first year at the helm john succeeded in
turning bill McFeely's popular lecture
course with over 200 students into a
teeny-tiny seminar the truth is John
wasn't much of a lecturer but in private
in small groups
he was hilariously funny a great
raconteur with an astonishing
encyclopedic grasp of the minutiae of
black history I ran into John a few
times as an undergraduate but the most
memorable time was on the steps in front
of Sterling we had never met have been
formally introduced I just happened to
be the person his eyes met as he glanced
up from something that he was reading he
was smoking a Winston and holding a
picture an image now quite famous of a
slave whose back was covered with deep
deep keloid welts running the length of
his torso from waist to neck like a
river delta and John had tears in his
eyes can you believe that a human being
could do this to another human being he
asked me I didn't even know what to say
but I never forgot that image and I I
never forgot the pain look on his face I
would recall that encounter when I
walked into Naples on my first day of
work as Secretary be in the program of
afro-american studies the first thing in
the morning on the first Monday in
October 1975 bearing a message from
Charles T Davis our chair to his errant
Knight John blasini Blass read it and
invited me to sit down turning his face
to avoid blowing smoke into mine and in
the sense I never got up from that chair
as for the man who had sent me there
Charles Davis he had come to campus as
the first tenured african-american in
the English department and soon became
the first black master of Calvin College
I was actually a junior at Yale when I
met Charles Davis my girlfriend big
Junior your item Linda darling now the
well-known Linda darling-hammond
Linda darling and I had persuaded mr.
Davis to supervise a directed reading
course on the history of black popular
culture second set second semester of
that year we were an item as they say
and madly in love foolishly in love we
had decided to take several classes
together during that second semester the
only problem was ladies and gentlemen
that come mid-february we broke up so we
decided to divide up the courses and
share each other's notes to avoid each
other's most unpleasant company
she drew mr. Davis's tutorial we wrote
the paper together for the final grade
but she covered the tutorial meetings I
was too embarrassed every to try to
explain to Charles Davis why it never
occurred to me that I would one day be
at his mercy after a couple weeks at the
Yale Law School I realized that what I'd
really wanted to do was to complete my
PhD dissertation in English which I had
begun at Cambridge and teach African and
African American literature and so out
of sheer desperation I went to see
Charles Davis over at Calhoun to see if
he could give me some advice about the
job meaning find me a job after
reminding me that my attendance in our
tutorial three years before had been
rather spotty he sized up the situation
quickly and ascertained that I did have
in the end one special talent I was a
fast typist and just by luck the program
had a vacancy and he hired me on the
spot I walked back up Wall Street and I
took a leave of absence from the from
the law school and the last time I
checked ladies and gentlemen I was still
on leave
and for the next nine months I found
myself typing much of the correspondence
in manuscripts for the Faculty of Yale's
afro-american studies program before mr.
Davis managed to get me promoted to a
lectureship in English an avro am not
bad for a secretary and that's how I
ended up delivering Davis's message to
Blasingame that first day of work on
that first Monday in October
truth be told Charles and John weren't
especially fond of each other after all
they were studying contrasts consider
John was tall Charlie was short John was
descended from southern slaves most
definitely filled Charlie from a long
line of well-educated northern teachers
preachers and professionals probably
descended as he'd like to claim from
slaves who had served in the big house
John was dark complexioned Charlie liked
complexions
Charlie thought that John was brash
country uncouth John for his part
thought that Charlie put on airs and was
Busey and sadiddy' with it John was
always an administrator in a hurry
Charlie on the other hand saw the
history of academic disciplines in
decades nineteen months putting memo and
he thought the confrontation was the
last resort of the week and the
unimaginative Charlie's weapons of
choice were a martini a mint julep a
Smithfield ham and piping hot biscuits
Charlie thought the President and
provost were the local embodiment of
Western civilization and that his job as
a leader of the academic vanguard of the
race was to show them both that the
Negro knew which fork to use at a dinner
party on Martha's Vineyard John thought
that the Provost's office was a Treasury
to be plundered
to create incremental professorships a
graduate program and research support
for his faculty Charlie lived much of
the spring in anticipation of the
Kentucky Derby which he thought of as
the two most exciting as the most
exciting two minutes in all of sports as
he was fond of repeating especially as
April melted into Maine Charlie owned a
beautiful white linen suit and white
books which he wore only one day a year
and that was on the day of the Kentucky
Derby he would assemble certain members
of the faculty and friends for a
cocktail party never
John blasting imply them with mint
juleps and that Smithfield ham and those
biscuits in anticipation of the starting
bell rarely have I seen an adult derive
more pleasure from a single sporting
event John for his part thought that the
Kentucky Derby was a holdover from
slavery and best should be boycotted for
all their differences of temperament
experience and background they knew deep
down that they needed each other
they realized that there was not one way
to be a scholar of afro-american studies
and they knew that each had weaknesses
and blind spots for which only the other
could compensate through it all
nonetheless they maintained a certain
grudging respect for each other and
perhaps even a certain peculiar sort of
affection and it is from their widely
varying approaches and personalities
that we modeled our own plan for action
when Anthony and I went up to Harvard to
take a leadership role in our field with
a considerable help and support of many
my colleagues in this room in fact
virtually every departure we attempted
over the last two decades emerged either
from a certain seminar presided over at
Naples pizza shop by one John W
Blasingame or that other seminar
presided over by Charles Davis in the
Masters living room at Calhoun College
if there's anyone who deserves to be
honored for reinventing the field of
african-american studies in the 70s and
80s a fashion it into a form that would
flourish into the 21st century it is
Charles T Davis
and john w blessing him senior and I'm
so happy that the very best of what they
represent is alive and well right here
in New Haven Connecticut under the
leadership of Elizabeth Alexander and
the brilliant colleagues in your
department thank you ladies and
gentlemen thank you my friends for
conferring this great honor